well I think it's very very clear that
we need a wider array of more effective
treatments for PTSD no question
MDMA was actually first synthesized and
patented by merck pharmaceutical he
synthesized it in 1912 and patented in
1914 so but they never really did
anything with it and then in the 70s
alexander sasha shogun made some and
tried it experimented with it and he and
Dave Nichols published the first report
of human experience with MDMA and out of
that grew the interest you know he
thought immediately this is probably
could be useful as a therapeutic tool
but there were quite a number of
psychologists psychiatrists other
therapists using it kind of as a
catalyst for therapy in this late 70s
early 80s it was not a improved drug but
it wasn't illegal either in 82 I came
out to study with Stan Grof and
Christina Groff at Esalen and somebody
came to the month-long workshop with
MDMA and at first I was unimpressed the
way they described it because I thought
it's not the the bells and whistles and
the whole lightening and all this from
Millis tea or anything it was just
quietly helps you to talk to each other
and feel your emotions and I was like I
feel fine they're ready what I need it
for but I thought I should buy some
anyway and give it a try so I tried MDMA
with my girlfriend and it was just a
revelation about how profound it is and
at the same time I realized that it was
starting to be sold as ecstasy so I and
it was also the rise of the Nancy Reagan
just say no so I knew that it was
inevitably going to be crushed so in 84
I started a non-profit before Maps that
was the whole community together the the
therapists and the researchers and and
so we had a chance where it was legal to
try to build a base of support and
witnesses for a potential legal case and
that's where I contacted Robert Mueller
at the United Nations
the assistant secretary-general and he
helped me to meet a lot of religious
professionals who I sent MDMA to and
they tried it in monasteries and all
these places and and so we ended up in -
in 1984 the DEA moved to criminalize
MDMA and so we I went to Washington and
filed for an administrative law judge
hearing which to our utter astonishment
we won and the judge said that MDMA
should stay in schedule 3 it should be
illegal for non-medical use but
therapists and psychiatrists should be
able to have it available to their
patients but then the DEA administrator
overruled that and put it in schedule 1
so that's where I started maps in 86 and
the idea was that there is no way but
through the FDA that the drug war is too
powerful but maybe through science and
medicine we can make some progress it's
kind of an epidemic of PTSD now with all
the veterans coming back from Iraq and
Afghanistan to say nothing of all the
countries where there's armed conflict
and even higher levels of PTSD so it's a
huge public health problem they're
desperate last year was about
five-and-a-half billion dollars that the
VA spent on disability payments for
veterans with PTSD as a veteran in
Vietnam 65 66 out of the Huey battalion
and I came back in a pretty good case in
Postbank Vestas disorder and it was
really hard for a long time holding jobs
relationships and stuff and I saw this
they going to CNN about using some of
the psychedelics to relieve the symptoms
and I did it and it was wonderful it
really helped help me get my feet back
on the ground from a kind of a
therapeutic point of view what we think
it it seems to do is kind of decrease
fear and defensiveness anxiety increase
a sense of trust but also help people
connect with their emotions I think the
National Geographic had a great analogy
it's like
you threw a house and all the Glock
closets are open there's nothing you
can't explore in your own psyche and
it's just like magic but the wonderful
thing you don't have to keep taking it
for the rest of your life our first
study that we completed and published
was with mostly people with childhood
sexual abuse or rape they all had to
have had therapy and medications before
and not not been helped adequately and
they'd have either two or three all day
eight to ten our MDMA sessions in our
office with both of us and my wife and I
present male and female Kythera pused is
the model we use and so we just spend
that whole time with them so that we
don't give take home MDMA they only get
it under direct supervision among the
people that I'm got the MDMA with
therapy basically eighty-three percent
had a good clinical response versus 25%
with the therapy only well it's been 27
years so far and we're now about two to
three years away from what's called the
end of phase two meeting with the FDA so
all of what we're doing is preliminary
none of the data that we are gathering
now in our five or six small pilot
studies around the world will count
towards making MDMA into a medicine all
that we're doing is trying to figure out
how to design the phase three studies
and we anticipate hopefully that they'll
start in around three years they'll take
four or five years again it depends on
resources and stuff like that and then a
year or so for the FDA to evaluate the
data so by the end of 2021 we're hoping
that MDMA would be a prescription
medicine if this is in fact something
that can help a lot of people and the
we're at this stage of the research
which is you know at least twenty years
behind where it would be if people if it
had been guided only by science and not
by politics and fears and other forces
that's really actually it
travesty